you spend a lot of time in Oakland
making your new show this is also his
blind spotting so do you do people
recognize you there are they like what's
that yeah but they don't care because
they're too cool what I mean they care
in the nice way but not in the annoying
way this is I love that I love fans yeah
people are like love you and they're on
their way exactly great no that's
winning yeah that's right or if you've
done a show that means a lot to you and
they go I got that that's or I'm sure if
you have a song that they really got
yeah and you're like all right yeah this
is um the second season of this show
Blind spotting on Stars based on the
movie
Diggs and Rafael Casal made and starred
in and now they've created this show
this is our second season and it's it's
so beautiful I didn't make it so like my
daughter's album which I my daughter and
her friend Raya Gardens album that I had
nothing to do with I can promote it
shamelessly
beautiful show it's about the effects of
incarceration on the whole rest of the
family in the community and it's a
really laugh out loud comedy yeah and
there's incredible choreography by
little buck and John boogs and their
spoken word which I do somehow
yeah David is so funny
um yes I love him so you you've
described your character as a hippie
loud mommy do you relate to that at all
because I do when I first got the part
I'm like how am I gonna play this you
literally just said three things that
are me oh really
um yeah so you know I put together what
she wears I've got a wig that's got a
little more gray than I have and yeah
she's the loud liberal if no one in the
room is gonna say it I'm gonna say it
yeah and then I got to work and it was
time to get dressed and I took off my
Birkenstocks and put on her Birkenstocks
I took off my legs and put on her legs I
rolled up my graying hair and put her
and I was like there's no character here
at all it's just like hanging out in my
skin it's just me that's fun yeah and I
got hired to do it what what did you
learn about playing the role did you
know a lot about incarceration how it
affects the family yeah I mean for
different reasons I've been
you know as a white woman had the
privilege to learn about it more slowly
than other people in our country because
it saturates my community slightly less
than people of color but first of all
you know the prison for profit thing is
yeah it's hard to wake up in the morning
knowing that I remember finding that out
yeah no it's it's devastating in this
show there have been beautiful uh books
and documentaries and movies made about
that and this show is talking about the
effects on the mothers and the sons and
the wives and the sisters and the best
friends and the loved ones the
concentric circle of of suffering yeah
the system causes and somehow think
about it yeah
unless it's impacting you yeah yeah wow
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]